look sometimes in life or in courier
you're gonna hit a wall and you feel
like you're stuck or you're plateaued
and you almost don't know what to do but
it's important to realize why we Plateau
so today I'm gonna talk about three
different reasons why people plateau on
business and life number one you are
secretly content with where you're at
but no one knows about it let me explain
a position and income a status you go to
the parties you always wanted to go to
you live in a community you want it so
you're very happy where you're at just
no one knows your content number two no
one around you has the guts to tell you
the truth about adjustments you need to
be making so if you don't have the
people around you who are free to tell
you things that you may be doing wrong
you don't really know you may have some
blind spots that you don't know about
and last but not least number three is
your fire for learning that curiosity
that you had that got you to the point
you're out right now that flare that
fire is no longer lit you need to light
that thing up and start learning again
wanted to find out what to do next
reading book studying what am I going
through what do I need to do to take the
business to the next level so you can
get passed to your current level of
Plateau or the wall that you have
currently hit
[Music]